لفتني هذا اخر كتاب مش اخر ده قبل هذا
مجموعه قصائد نعم ندبه اوليس نعم هذه
الندبه نذبت بوليس وهي انطولوجيا شعريه
فيها مختارات من خمس دواوين شعريه الاخيره
الكتاب هذه
ترجمه
لكتاب الشعر على الفرات
وقصائد اخرى صدر في ايطاليا بتقديم للشاعر
الايطالي الكبيرتي
ايطاليا هذه المجموعه شعريه المستحيمات
باللغه الايطاليه ايضا ترجمه الى
الايطاليه همم
هذا عمل شعري باللغه الانجليزيه يعني زرقه
المساء
لي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه قطرها حول الشفوي
طبعا
وهذا العمل اذن كالحب مجموعه الشعريه
باللغه الفرنسيه
وقدم لها الكاتبه
الحب هذا حوار مع الدكتور المهدي المزرعه
المفكر المغربي الكبير راحل رحمه الله هذا
الكتاب الكتاب والتشكيل في عده الدراسات
ومقالات هدوم 15 ما قاله ودراسه
لمحمد الاشعري لسعدي يوسف لعدد من النقاد
حول روايه
روايه جترد كتب حولها اكثر من 40 دراسه
واعتبرت ان خطاب هذا العمل الروائي وخطاب
ما بعد كولونياله هدير جيت شتايم الروائي
الامريكي كانت مقيمه في فرنسا
واشتهرت بالخصوص بانها كانت من هواه جمع
اللوحات لكبار الفنانين وعلى راسهم بيكاسو
وبيكاسو واعمل لها بورتريه سنه 1906 هو
هذا البورتريه
ايضا ترجمه
اللغه الامازيغيه المغربيه